[Music]
foreign
good morning to you there are
expectations this morning of another
major reversal to the mini budget the
chancellor quasi quateng has cut
shortest trip to the international
monetary Fund in Washington and is
returning to the UK earlier than planned
this follows days of open Revolt amongst
Tory MPS but Mr quateng insists his job
is safe and that he's going nowhere
pressure is also growing on the Prime
Minister Liz truss to save her
Administration her key pledge to scrap
the planned increase in corporation tax
from 19 to 25 is widely seen as a likely
casualty in the coming days
so let's just remind you of What's led
up to this latest turn of events well
three weeks ago quasi-quarting announced
his so-called mini budget speaking in
the Commons he promised to make tax cuts
worth 45 billion pounds the pound
slumped almost immediately and fell to
its lowest level in 37 years by
mid-afternoon
following Fallout over the weekend
Sterling fell close to 1.3 cents a
record low for the pound
the bank of England then stepped in
launching a huge 65 billion pound
intervention to stop a run on Pension
funds
the night before his speech at the Tory
Party Conference the chancellor you
turned on his planned to scrap the 45
Pence top rate of income tax paid by
those earning more than 150 000 pounds
the bank of England Governor Andrew
Bailey then announced it wouldn't extend
its support of the guilt Market Beyond
its deadline of today
and leaving a meeting with the IMF
yesterday the chancellor refused to rule
out another U-turn this time on
corporation tax
from Washington our U.S correspondent
Mark Stone reports
an airport dash for a Chancellor Under
Pressure quasi-quartang's car
disappeared into the Washington night
after an embassy event and a hastily
rearranged early departure
he'd spent the day at the international
monetary fund's annual meeting defending
his mini budget even as rumors of
another U-turn swirled across the
Atlantic our position hasn't changed I
will come up with the medium-term fiscal
plan on the 31st of October as I said
earlier in the week and there'll be more
detail there and you'll be Chancellor
and Liz truss will be prime minister
this time next month absolutely 100 I'm
not going anywhere
he wasn't at the big meetings through
the day like the G20 Gathering of
Finance ministers and Bank Chiefs
words move markets and so there were
very few here the German bank chief so
what's your reaction to what's happening
in the UK at the moment
the European Central Bank president
what's your what's your reaction to
what's happening in the UK the U.S
treasury secretary what's your message
to the UK Chancellor at the moment
but the chancellor wasn't here instead a
UK official red government binder in
hand explained to organizers that a
deputy would step in for the closed-door
meeting not entirely unusual but
surprising given that they do all want
to know what's happening in London any
reason why the chancellor wasn't there
that's a question
a few rooms away the IMF boss arrived
for her keynote news conference we have
a world economy that has been hit
by one shock after another
an unrelented pandemic
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
climate disasters on all continents
it was a sobering reminder of a global
economy on the Rocks you said um in your
opening remarks that a complex time
requires steady hands on the policy
levers so my question simply is do you
think the British government's hands are
steady if the evidence is that there has
to be a recalibration it is right for
governments to do so the bank of England
action was appropriate there was a
Financial
Risk to financial stability
she and the chancellor met before his
early departure the focus the IMF says
was the importance of policy coherence
the chancellor is back in London early
he says to focus on a coherent fiscal
plan Mark Stone Sky News in Washington
what joining me now is international
trade Minister Greg hands very good
morning thanks for coming in why is the
chancellor flying back from the IMF in
Washington early well he has been there
for two days he's had extensive meetings
with World Financial leaders Finance
Minister Central Bank Governors It's Not
Unusual I've been a government Minister
about 10 years to come back a day early
from an international visit he's coming
back for discussions with colleagues we
obviously have the medium-term fiscal
plan coming up on the 31st of October so
just in a couple of weeks time there's
work to be done there's conversations to
be had with colleagues but the major uh
meet of the meetings of the IMF and the
World Bank have finished and the Prime
Minister and the chances Checker has
been there now for two days I think it's
not unusual to come back a day early so
he's coming back for discussions with
colleagues are
u-turns on any aspects of the mini
budget being considered as part of those
discussions well I mean they I saw the
Prime Minister yesterday the Prime
Minister and the chancellor are
absolutely determined to deliver on the
growth plan that is what the country
needs that's what the economy needs uh
the chance they'll be setting out his
plans it's not right for me to speculate
uh just two weeks in advance of those
plans I was a treasury Minister myself
Chief Secretary of the Treasury before I
think we're just gonna have to wait and
see what the chancellor says in the
medium-term fiscal plan on the 31st of
October but it's possible there'll be
reversals well look let's wait and see
you won't have long to wait
um to the 31st of October for the
chancellor to lay out those plans I do
say that the Prime Minister and the
chancellor are absolutely Resolute
determined the growth plan the
centerpiece but we'll have to see some
of the detail including a full forecast
from the office for Budget
responsibility on the 31st of October
let me just ask you about a couple of
aspects because a lot of people it will
affect a lot of people after all what
about the scrapping of the rise in
National Insurance well that definitely
go ahead
they well that's already been voted on
in the House of Commons got voted on on
uh Tuesday or Wednesday evening of this
week
um so that is going ahead uh that's
already been voted on it's already been
okay so that's going ahead what about
the scrapping of the rising corporation
tax then well uh in terms of as I said
the chancellor the Prime Minister
absolutely determined to stick to their
plans but let's wait and for the uh how
this will all pan out in the wider
scheme in the medium term fiscal plan
that you won't have long to wait for
comes before the end of the month do you
rule out any changes to the mini budgets
well I'm not going to speculate on the
medium-term fiscal plan that's going to
be coming on the 31st of October before
the end of the month as I say the Prime
Minister and the chancellor are
absolutely determined Resolute I've
worked very closely uh with both of them
in government I was Liz truss is number
two at trade before quasi quaten's
number two at the business department I
know them well and I know how determined
they are to deliver economic growth
deliver on the growth plan some of the
detail The Wider context will quite
rightly have to wait for for the median
term fiscal plan published on Monday and
two weeks so they want to push ahead
with their growth plan but you talk
about the details some of the detail
could change well I'm saying that some
of the detail will be laid out on the
31st of October again with the full
forecast from the office of budget
responsibility the full scorecard in a
usual Treasury and office of budget
responsibility way working together
working together as it should be that's
a long time to wait the 31st of October
are we not going to get any update later
today will we get an update today on how
the government is going to respond to
the the market turmoil well look the
government will make responses as
appropriate as events happen but the the
the absolutely commitment is to publish
the medium-term fiscal plan this is
looking at how the government is going
to pay for everything how the government
is going to set its budget in the coming
years and that will be laid out in just
two weeks time well yes but we're in the
middle of Market turmoil the Market's
clearly are speculating as well about
whether there'll be changes to the mini
budget not least corporation tax the
George Osborne former Chancellor of
course thinks that decisions should be
made quicker than that let's take a look
at what he tweeted yesterday given the
pain being caused the real economy by
the financial turbulence it's not clear
why it's in anyone's interest to wait 18
more days before the inevitable u-turn
on the mini budget well look I used to
work for George Osborne for many years
as his chief secretary to the treasury
so I know him well but I do think the
government has been absolutely clear
that the plans the detail plans will be
laid out the medium-term fiscal plan
coming before the end of the month
there's only a couple of weeks the
chancellor of course gave interviews
yesterday in Washington on the current
situation in regards to the global
turmoil and financial markets of course
there's a not something happening just
in the UK there are some specific UK
things going on but there is a global
problem going on with the both the rise
in Energy prices the rise in global
inflation uh there's been interventions
not only in this country the bank of
Japan has had to intervene the Yen has
fallen to a 30-year low this is not a UK
only thing but as you say there are
elements that are absolutely specific to
the UK and useful to Richie sunac in his
campaign for leadership and he said it
would be complacent and irresponsible to
ignore the risks of the markets losing
confidence in the British economy he
also warned that what he described as
Liz truss's unfunded spending
commitments he said they would force up
inflation and interest rates and
increase borrowing costs he was right
wasn't he well I mean different things
were said during the conservative
leadership contest which of course is a
entirely natural thing the two
candidates are laid out their approaches
their stalls uh Liz trussa as you
rightly pointed out I voted for Rishi
zunak but this trust why on that contest
she's delivering on the plans
right about what those plans is
delivering on the plans that she laid
out during that leadership contest we've
got more detail to come in the
medium-term fiscal plan uh before the
end of the month and it's right that the
conservative party uh be United behind
our selected conservative party leader
and now prime minister Liz truss would
the markets have more confidence if
Rishi sunak was prime minister as you'd
wanted him to be well there's always
these kind of what if style questions uh
but you know as we know from the
leadership contest uh Richardson act did
not win the leadership contest Liz trust
did win the leadership contest I am
dealing with the situation uh that we
are in which is that Liz truss is our
prime minister she has my confidence she
should have the confidence of all
conservative MPS the whole conservative
party and actually deserves the
confidence of the country as we go into
quite difficult Economic Times with the
rise in energy driven by Vladimir
Putin's invasion of train the turmoil
and Global Financial markets we need to
get behind our prime minister as a party
and show Liz trust the confidence that
she deserves in quasi-quarting to make
these difficult decisions going forward
you say we should have confidence in the
Prime Minister and the chancellor if
there were more changes to the mini
budget there's always already been one
big reversal is quasi-cutting's position
turnable I think totally I mean quasi
quatang himself said yesterday was 100
sure he will still be in position I know
the Prime Minister has got total
confidence in quasi-karting I've worked
very closely with quasi is an incredibly
capable person a very very bright person
who makes a good judgment calls and I
have absolute confidence that causes
chance of this tracker so if he was to
introduce some kind of change to
corporation tax either reverse his plan
or to to have corporation tax Rise by a
smaller amount you still think that his
he has credibility with the market it
well you're asking me to speculate well
it's the speculation that the markets
are doing that a lot of Tory MPS are
pushing for but it's not right for me to
speculate what I am saying is the prime
minister and the Chance executor are
absolutely determined on their course
and more detail be laid out before too
long in the medium-term fiscal plan on
the 31st of October the times is
reporting that what they describe as
senior conservatives are holding talks
about replacing Liz truss with a joint
ticket of Rishi sunak and Penny Morton
you're shaking your head have you heard
anything about that I don't recognize
that story at all uh I was a supporter
of Rishi zunak over the summer I'd be
very surprised at that story I was
talking only yesterday with Penny
Morton's I I don't recognize that story
at all but what we do need to do is the
conservative party does need to unite to
bind our prime minister she was our
choice of the conservative party just a
few weeks ago we need to Romania United
get together behind Liz truss
quasi-quartang as our team even though
her policies have caused turmoil on the
markets and seen people's mortgage rates
shoot up well I disagree with that yes
there are some UK specific factors but
overall the uh Global situation caused
originally of course by Vladimir Putin's
Invasion Ukraine the uh also the
recovery of the economy coming out of
the pandemic you know these are a
backdrop across all G7 countries you
know this year and last year the UK is
growing stronger than any other G7
country we are our position we have some
some serious issues coming up but other
countries are facing a similar set of
problems the rise in Energy prices the
turmoil and Global Market intervention
by central banks around the world rises
in interest rates rises in mortgage
rates energy price crunches in different
European countries and there's a lot
going on in the world situation in the
world economy but a lot of economists
including ones at the bank of England
would say this is UK specific well I
think we heard they would take into
account the global factors but they
would say there are some UK specific
problems but we heard in your clip
earlier from the head of the IMF about
global forces and Global turmoil you
know that is the principal focus of the
the IMF meeting that's just been
happening has been looking at those
global forces the interventions that
have been needed some of the problems a
lot of countries are facing with energy
our European neighbors are facing a very
significant crunch on both energy Supply
and energy prices you know these are
something that are not unique to the UK
according and Liz truss going to be in
their positions in a month's time
absolutely okay Craig Hans we appreciate
your time thanks very much and thank you
so let's take a look then how the papers
are reporting this growing pressure on
the government and the financial times
first of all reports on rumors that list
trust is poised to reverse some of the
policies in the recent mini budget
the guardian suggests that any U-turn
would be a significant blow to
mistrust's Authority
the express believes a change of
direction would calm at the markets
The Daily Telegraph leads with the
Chancellor's vow to fight on insisting
he's not going anywhere
according to the times a disgruntletory
MPS are looking to replace Liz trust
with one of her leadership competitors
where she sunak or penny mordant
The Daily Mail says she has just 17 days
to save her job
do you say whether it's not come on the
show I'm going to be speaking to the
shadow climate secretary Ed miliband
also ahead protesting the rising energy
costs I'll speak to the restaurant owner
who's going to Back to Basics and
serving a meal without the use of gas or
electricity
and the emergency rescue plan by the
bank of England ends today how will
Market be affected I'll speak to a
senior economic advisor to the house
treasury committee
Now new video has been released showing
increasingly panicked calls being made
by Leading politicians trapped in the
U.S capital when rioters stormed the
building in January last year during
what was expected to be the final
hearing into the attack by Donald Trump
supporters a congressional committee
also voted to subpoena the former
president to force him to give evidence
about his role from Washington James
Matthews reports
the door has been breached if it were
gaining access into the capital they
held back this film for the final stages
new footage from behind the scenes at
the Capitol Senator Schumer is at a
security
camera they're putting on their tear gas
masks
[Music]
from secure rooms beneath the building
politicians negotiated protection from
the mall for themselves and for a
government we have some Senators who are
still in their hideaways they need
massive Personnel now can you get the
Maryland National Guard to come to
[Applause]
yeah why don't you get the president to
tell them to leave the capitol Mr
attorney general he admitted he had lost
the election this Committee hearing said
the evidence showed an effort by Donald
Trump to ignore the rule of law and stay
in power let's get right to the violence
violence before voting said Roger Stone
in video that featured well-known Trump
allies and talk of ignoring an election
the key thing to do is to claim victory
possession is nine tenths a lottery he's
going to declare victory but that
doesn't mean he's the winner he's just
gonna say the word we were shown Secret
Service emails dated before January the
6th evidence said this committee that
Trump was aware of impending violence
their plan is to literally kill people
please please take this tip seriously
and investigate further
it is a body of evidence around January
the 6th that Donald Trump has been
summoned to address the committee that
accuses him has subpoenaed the former
president to give evidence
I am offering this resolution
that the committee direct the chairman
to issue a subpoena
for Relevant documents and testimony
under oath from Donald John Trump
these Congressional hearings have
amounted to a pool together of a case
against Donald Trump surrounding the
attack on the capital whether that's
heard and tested in an actual courtroom
will be a matter for this country's
justice department
whether he entertains his Committee of
accusers in the meantime is open to
question Donald Trump has already
dismissed its work as a politically
motivated Witch Hunt James Matthews Sky
News in Washington
families are victims of a Florida school
shooting are outright have outraged the
shooter was spared at the death penalty
24 year old Nicholas Cruz pleaded guilty
to murdering 14 students and three staff
members in 2018 but jurors could not
unanimously agree that he should be
given the death penalty and at least one
juror voted for a life sentence instead
families of the victims sobbed and
comforted each other as they heard the
jury's decision
what it says to me what it says to my
family what it says to the other
families is that his life meant more
than the 17 that were murdered and the
17 that were shot and the thousands of
people in that school in that community
that are terrorized and traumatized
every single day
I'm disgusted with the system
that you can allow
17 dead and 17 others shot and wounded
and not give the death penalty what do
we have the death penalty for
what is the purpose of it
you set a precedent today
you said the president for the next Mass
killing and nothing happens to you
you'll get life in jail
I'm sorry that is not okay
the children's commissioner has asked
all police forces in England and Wales
to provide figures on how many children
have been strip searched by officers
since 2018. well let's speak to our
correspondent Melena vaselinovich who
can tell us more about this so Melania
tell us a little bit more of the
background and what's prompted this call
but this was triggered by an incident in
which a 15 year old black schoolgirl
wore strip searched by two female met
police officers but without another
adult present because she was wrongly
suspected of carrying cannabis now a
safeguarding review found that that
should have never happened and that
racism likely played a part the Met
apologized but it did trigger this probe
into how many children in strip searched
and the answer is 650 in a two-year
period and this probe the previous probe
by the children's commissioner also
found that worrying lean a quarter of
those cases there was no appropriate
adult present now that could be a parent
or a guardian or someone like a social
worker it also found that black boys
were disproportionately searched for
example in 2018 two-thirds of all boys
who were searched were black so that all
prompted the children's commissioner to
widen this probe into all forces in
England and Wales so she could in her
own words reassure herself that this is
not a systemic problem now the Met
police has responded to this and in a
statement they said ensuring the
safeguarding of every child who is
subject to a search is an absolute
priority we got it wrong with child Q
which is the 15 year old girl and we are
making significant efforts to ensure our
approach puts the child at the heart of
decision making we have been listening
to our communities and partners and have
made changes as we balance the policing
need for this type of search with a
considerable impact it can have on young
people and their children's
Commissioners says that the strip search
of children's very intrusive should only
be done when it's very urgent to do so
in order to either save the life of the
child or protect others not as a routine
exercise and the results of this new
wider probe will be published early next
year
Milena thanks very much indeed
let's return to our top story now the
chancellor quasi quateng is returning
from London from to London from
Washington early as another mini budget
U-turn is expected well I'm joined Now
by conservative peer Lord vasey uh very
good morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us this morning what do you
make of the fact that the chancellor is
cutting short his trip to the IMF
meetings in Washington
is this a sign of the government in
crisis
it's not a good sign it doesn't look
like the government is in uh control Jim
Callahan the labor prime minister in the
1970s family famously came back from the
IMF conference in the Caribbean I think
and came back to the headline crisis
what crisis and I'm afraid that the
chancellor coming back a day early
doesn't fill one with confidence I can
see on your Ticker on the Sky News
screen that Greg hands the new trade
Minister who's a Rishi sunak supporter
and a sign that the government is now
trying to broaden its support is saying
it's not unusual but it is quite unusual
for this to happen
and so what do you expect to happen to
during the course of today do you think
that revisions to the mini budget more
revisions to the mini budgets or on the
cards
I think it looks inevitable I mean the
government has absolutely no easy
choices after the mini budget caused
such a catastrophic um
economic crisis I think that there may
be uh I think it is inevitable there
will be changes to the mini budget what
is now kind of being mooted is perhaps
there'll be some sort of compromise that
can still be presented as radical
economics as in corporation tax will
rise famously quasi-quarting reverse the
Rishi sunak plan to put uh corporation
tax up from 19 to 25 but maybe he'll put
it up say to 21 to 22 and say it's still
not as high as it would have been under
Rishi sunak although he is now trying to
balance the books the other key reversal
might be that he's already done a U-turn
in when he's going to make his statement
on public spending to the end of October
maybe he'll bring that forward as well
and that would justify his coming back
early from Washington
but what would that do to his authority
if he did have to make changes like that
well this is the uh terrible dilemma the
government faces itself in because
obviously you rely on the authority of
the Prime Minister and the chancellor to
give confidence to the markets and
therefore to boost the economy uh if he
does a U-turn like this it will be very
damaging to his authority can he get
through it who knows the fact that
people are speculating about the prime
minister's leadership this early in her
Premiership is not ideal uh but I think
he's just got to bite the bullet he's
got to try and give the markets
confidence in the British economy and if
he can do that then perhaps he can say
well I had to do some difficult choices
slightly humiliating choices but the
result is stabilization I can now move
forward
so you think he can survive he can
introduce changes more changes to the
mini budget and still keep his job
yes I think he can survive partly
because if he went it would expose the
Prime Minister even more
um
it is always possible I mean the trouble
that the Tory party has is if they have
lost confidence in the Prime Minister
and the chancellor what on Earth do they
do I don't think the country could
stomach yet another leadership change so
if the situation is that the chancellor
has to make a slightly embarrassing well
very embarrassing you turn on his mini
budget but can get through it and the
Market's calm down then one can have a
period of calm in which he can try and
re-establish his authority so it is not
inevitable that if he makes changes that
he has to go
you say that the party couldn't stomach
another leadership change and yet there
are reports in today's Times newspaper
for example of a joint sunak Penny
mordant ticket have you heard any rumors
like that
I haven't heard those rumors it wouldn't
surprise me if people were speculating
about that I mean the trouble is that
Richardson in effect he and his allies
predicted this kind of economic problem
if Liz truss went ahead with her radical
pro-growth um reforms at a time of
economic uncertainty so there is a
certain amount dare I say of schaden
Freud I suspect on the part of Rishi
sinak supporters if there was to be a
change of leadership and at the moment I
couldn't really countenance it it would
have to be the case that Tory MPS would
simply have to choose Rishi sunuk as
their prime minister and say that was a
done deal let's get on with it but at
the moment I think it would be
almost impossible to see them making
that choice at this stage because it
just would look chaotic
what is the mood though would you say
amongst Tory back benches
well I think the mood is is relatively
Bleak in the sense that this is a
self-inflicted wound we didn't have to
have a mini budget that was so radical
and which wasn't joined up both with tax
cuts accompanied by proposals on public
spending but having said that I think uh
there is also a yearning for the current
leadership to steady the ship so to give
them the opportunity in the next couple
of weeks to do the things that may be
necessary in order to get back on the
course uh
even if they do that and they get back
on course and people criticize them and
then say what is the point of a trust
government the fact is that they I think
it would be preferable for the
conservative party to keep the current
leadership in place uh and to move
forward and you know it sounds a bit
trite to put it like this but to put
this behind them and reset the
government's agenda
you talk about the things that are
necessary to to get them back on course
what are those things what steps do need
to be taken to study the ship
well the fundamental point is joined up
uh economics so the fundamental point to
get the ship back on course is to say uh
that uh we're going to as it were change
course in terms of the depth of the tax
cuts we were proposing you've got to
remember that the 45p tax cut which in
it it in the cold light of day was a
potentially sensible move to simplify
the tax system and it was something that
George Osborne would have liked to have
done but the politics defeated him in
2010 uh was it was a very small tax cut
in the scheme of things the key point is
the gap between the level of tax cuts
and the level of public spending cuts
that are needed to meet that and Liz
truss has been put in the corner because
the party is made quite clear that they
wouldn't support a reduction in welfare
benefits so they've got to find a way to
uh go back on their mini budget but not
present it as a complete and utter
U-turn and to put Forward credit
credible public spending plans that
balance their tax reforms with their
public spending plans if the markets
accept that and Margaret Thatcher
famously said you cannot back the
markets if the markets accept that then
perhaps the government lives to fight
another day so they've got to just put
this behind them and get to a position
where there are no more kind of economic
shocks and economic shocks sound you
know kind of theoretical you know what's
happening in the bond market what does
that mean to you and me in real life it
means increases in interest rates it
means a hit on our mortgages and it
means economic uncertainty which is very
very scary for a lot of people the key
for me has always been if we can get
through the winter and people feel the
government has been on their side and
helped get through the winter and Liz
trust presented a pretty comprehensive
package on Energy prices and supporting
consumers and businesses on energy and
we can get through to the spring
relatively unscathed we're not going to
get through one scathe then the
government has a fighting chance so
that's what they have to do in the next
two weeks they have to calm the markets
and by calming the markets they calm the
economy they calm you and me as Citizens
and they calm their Tory MPS
okay advisee Lord vasey thanks very much
indeed for your time this morning we
appreciate it thanks
let's get the view of labor now I'm
joined here in the studio by Shadow
climate change secretary Ed miliband
very good morning to you it's good to be
with you
um so of course you can't tell the
chancellor is coming back from
Washington from the IMF meetings early
what do you read into that this is a
government in meltdown and economic
policy in tatters and frankly I think
the conservative party should be hanging
its head in shame what that is putting
the country through this is about
people's livelihoods people's homes
people's mortgages and you have a
government and let's be clear about why
this has happened you have a government
that embarked on the strategy of saying
let's have massive tax cuts for the
richest in society for big corporations
so-called trickle-down economics which
isn't going to work and also they're
trashing the Economic Institutions of
the country like the office of budget
responsibility that is why the markets
have reacted as they have that is why
there's been such a loss of confidence
in the government and the government's
economic policy and that's why the
budget has got to be ripped up well as
far as quasi question is concerned Greg
Hans he was in this studio in that seat
just a short while ago says It's Not
Unusual to to cut short trips to to the
IMF meetings and the main meetings had
already taken place
you know I think people will be furious
that the government is taking people for
fools you know let's I saw Greg hans's
interview and he says it's somehow that
this is a global phenomenon it is not a
global phenomenon there's no other
Finance Minister who's rushing back on
an airplane early from the IMF meetings
there's no other country where central
bank said to have an emergency buying
spree there's no other country where a
government's economic policy is falling
apart at the seams you know this is this
is a collective meltdown on the part of
the government and uh you know the
British people deserve so much better
than what this government is putting the
country through you say you want to see
the mini budget ripped up what elements
do you want to see reversed first of all
the corporation tax uh cart or the
refusal to go ahead with the rise which
was baked in let's be clear that's 18
billion pounds of unfunded tax cuts
there were other measures like the stamp
Duty cart like the abolishing vat for
foreign visitors here all kinds of
unfunded tax cuts in that category we
also need a proper windfall tax to help
fund the package and crucially this is
this is the two other really important
things we can't have a situation where
the independent office of budget
responsibility is locked in a Cupboard
because that's part of what led to the
problems we've seen you know they were
they were they were basically gagged by
the government and then crucially also
we need an economic strategy that is
credible in terms of growth you see the
government isn't wrong to say it wants
to see more growth and that they've
failed over 12 years they have failed
over 12 years to bring growth but we're
not going to get growth if we believe in
some extreme Fringe theory that cutting
taxes for the ultra wealthy is going to
produce growth we need to actually
invest in the country like in the green
economy of the future which is what a
labor government would do you say scrap
the mini budget and yet you support
elements of it don't you you support the
reversal of the National Insurance rise
the cut in the basic rate of income tax
all measures in the minimum well we led
the way in saying that the government
shouldn't be raising National Insurance
on ordinary families and we've said
we're not going to reverse if we were in
government and the basic rate cut which
was already programmed in is in place we
weren't going to reverse it but that's
because but that's because we that's
because we're not in favor of raising
taxes on ordinary people but more than a
half more than a half of the measures uh
in the mini budget were measures we
opposed we also said there should be a
proper windfall tax to help pay for the
energy price uh measures that were taken
and then it goes to this other point
which is what is your economic strategy
is there a credible economic strategy do
you are you trashing the institutions of
the country or are you upholding them
but you say you want the mini budgets
scrapped and yet you back key elements
of it you can't have it both ways well
no what we're saying is that we wouldn't
reverse the basic rate you know the
question we would face if we came into
government if the basic rate cut is in
place or and the National Insurance
um the reverse of the National Insurance
rise is would we raise taxes on ordinary
family he's on twelve and a half
thousand pounds a year well we're not
going to do that
um but let's be clear this is the
government that came forward with its
strategy it's got to go back to a blank
slate start again and come up with a
credible plan a credible plan with
fiscal numbers that add up do you have
fiscal numbers that add up we haven't
really seen Labor's costumes well
proposals well no that's not absolutely
not true we we cost we set out the the
costings for everything we propose you
know we've said for example that we
would have more doc nurses and doctors
and we've shown how getting rid of the
so-called non-dom status which allows
foreign citizens to be here and not pay
their taxes that could raise about three
billion pounds we've shown how we can
invest in education by getting rid of
the vat relief on private school for
yourself absolutely everything we we set
out everything we propose is fully
funded and that is the difference labor
is the responsible part in British
policy you know I was I was here a few
weeks ago saying that the the
conservatives were being fiscally
irresponsible by having an energy price
guarantee energy price package which was
only funded by borrowing not a windfall
tax bill so it was surprising Labor's
taking notorious for fiscal
irresponsibility and then we saw that
added to in the budget that
quasi-karting produced on the subject of
energy which obviously is your brain
you're talking about fracking today
you've been very critical of the
government's plan to lift the ban on
fracking so what are you going to do
about it well we are going to do
everything we can through the House of
Commons and there is support across the
House of Commons for for carrying on
with the ban on fracking uh to try and
force the government to change its mind
why is fracking not the answer first of
all it will make no difference to gas
prices because where the gas is produced
here or produced internationally we pay
the same price for it secondly the
government gave a categorical Assurance
in their Manifesto they said we are not
going to restart fracking unless it can
be categorically shown to be safe and
and they haven't got the evidence and
they're and they're breaking since then
Russia has invaded Ukraine that's had a
massive impact on Energy prices and they
say that it's in the National interest
to reintroduce more extreme Fringe views
from a government that is of the extreme
Fringe of the conservative party look
Boris Johnson opposed fracking
himself said a few months ago fracking
will make no difference to Energy prices
much better stop it well much better to
go ahead with Labor's plans for a clean
energy Sprint for zero carbon power
system by 2030. for example the
government is also talking about
blocking solar energy the equivalent of
10 nuclear power stations worth of solar
energy that's completely wrong solar
energy is the cheapest form of power
that we have how do we stop it we'll do
everything we can to work with MPS from
across parties conservative MPS I'm
talking to some conservative MPS we I
will do everything we can to try and
stop this how many Tory MPS are prepared
to go against the government well I I
don't know the answer to that but I know
there is a lot of disquiet from talking
to conservative MPS about this we'll we
will find a way of testing uh opinion in
the House of Commons you know we get
opposition days and we're thinking about
how we can use at that time uh to have
uh votes on fracking but we do want to
stop this and you know the other thing
is uh and and you know it's so clear
here to me that people in the country
don't want fracking it's the least
popular form of uh energy that they that
they can be but the government says
they'll only go ahead if they have local
concerns well they don't quite say that
Liz trust said that during her
leadership campaign that they haven't
they she cannot say what local consent
even means and there is a fear that they
can actually bypass local people when it
comes to fracking that will be quite
wrong and on the subject of of solar
Farms this trust did say she'd block
them on agricultural land during her
leadership campaign but her argument
would be wouldn't it that they we need
to boost food production at a time when
food prices are soaring and we can't
afford to import them and the biggest
threat to food security is the climate
crisis and you know how much because
listro has sort of made much of this
fact that solar Farms apparently
destroying all that Farmland do you know
how much Farmland is actually being used
by solar panels at the moment 0.1
percent one one thousandth of of uh
farmland and even if we increase solar
panels by five times it will be only
half a percent of Farmland I'm afraid
it's you see there is a piece of this
with with what we saw in the budget
we've got a party that has got dangerous
extreme views essentially taken over the
conservative party and is now trying to
impose those views on the country and it
is bad for the country it's the wrong
priorities for Britain I asked this
question to Greg hands do you expect um
to be in office in a month's time I have
absolutely no idea but you know what the
conservative party seems really worried
about the trashing of the conservative
party I'm worried about the trashing of
the country I'm worried about people's
mortgages I'm worried about the the
spectacle the the impact this is having
on people across Britain and I honestly
believe that the whole of the
conservative party Bears responsibility
for this they elected Liz truss they
they impose yet another prime minister
uh on us you know I feel like they
gambles at the casino they bet the house
on one prime minister then they get rid
of them and they bet the house on
another prime minister there's only one
answer for this which is the
conservative budget get out of the way
and let a labor government uh govern the
country okay Ed mediban thanks very much
thank you
well the chancellor was supposed to be
staying in Washington until later on
today so some people will be surprised
that he's cut his trip short but
International Trade secretary Greg hands
told me that his sudden change of plans
isn't out of the ordinary
It's Not Unusual I've been a government
Minister about 10 years to come back a
day early from an international visit
he's coming back for discussions with
colleagues we obviously have the
medium-term fiscal plan coming up on the
31st of October so just in a couple of
weeks time there's work to be done
there's conversations that we had with
colleagues are we not going to get any
update later today will we get an update
today on how the government is going to
respond to the the market turmoil well
look the government will make responses
as appropriate as events happen but the
uh the absolutely commitment is to
publish the medium-term fiscal plan
so our political correspondent Rob
Powell is here to chat through some of
those political interviews we've done
this morning and uh Greg hands there
very keen to say it's not unusual for a
Chancellor to cut short a trip to the
IMF in Washington nothing to see here
yeah quasi cartoon in the air now on the
way back from Washington cutting that
trip short by a day as you say Greg
hands a newly appointed trade Minister
saying that it's not unusual I don't
think that's quite the whole truth I
think given the given that the context
of what's going on on markets what's
going on here in the UK discussions that
have been going on in number 10 about
junking parts of the mini budget
um I think you it would be fair to read
a little bit more into shall we say that
and when you interviewed Lord Ed vasey
their conservative peer
um he said it wasn't quite right to say
this isn't unusual cutting shorter trip
like this
um was unusual in a circumstance in
circumstances
um like this so what do we read into it
well you asked Greg hands about whether
we could expect any more u-turns I think
he said let's see you question on some
some of the specifics of the mini budget
he said the National Insurance cut had
already gone through the commons so that
was set in stone but on corporation tax
which was set to rise Liz truss said
that wasn't going to happen and there's
been a lot of speculation
um that that could be one of the u-turns
I think his exact quote
um was that the chancellor in the PM
were determined to stick to the plan but
let's see how this pans out in the wider
scheme so still emphasizing I thought
that October the 31st date for the next
step of the gross plan to be laid out
that medium-term fiscal strategy people
in number 10 this morning are saying the
same thing they're saying October the
31st is the date it's very hard I think
when you package up the chancellor
coming back a day early with um what
we've seen really over the last couple
of weeks and what we may see in the
coming days on markets to think that the
government won't have to say something
before then in just over two weeks time
now what does that mean for the
political fortunes of both
quasi-quarting and Liz truss well I
expect that will play out in the coming
hours and days uh when quasi-quarters
sits down with Liz truss and they decide
um what to do Ed vasey seemed pretty
sure that they probably could cling on
maybe because the alternative having
another leadership contest
um was worse but I think for a prime
minister that spent all summer really
carving her political offering around
tax cuts if she's forced to junk all of
that it's very hard to see really how
she stays in place with any sort of
political Authority and labor meanwhile
calling for a scrapping of the mini
budget but there are key elements they
do back in it yeah this is the thing
with labor is that they want I think the
political attack line of saying get rid
of this mini budget but when you drill
down in some of the big specific
measures like a penny off basic rate of
income tax labor support that reversing
the National Insurance cut labor
supported that and they didn't even
oppose it in the Commons when it went
through
um on Tuesday so there's a little bit of
sort of political game playing going on
here and I think that speaks to a
broader Point within labor at the moment
that whilst they're waging quite an
effective attack campaign on the
conservatives I mean it's probably not
hard at the moment if we're being honest
actually when it comes to their own
figures and whether their own numbers
add up it's not at all clear that they
actually do okay well thanks very much
indeed and I'll see you a little bit
later on
let me just bring you a little bit of
breaking news that's just come into US
Royal Mail is Consulting on a program of
job carts which is expected to see
around 10 000 full-time roles axed by
August next year now this is according
to its parent group International
distribution services and we'll bring
you more details on that and more
reaction to that in the next hour
now with little government guidance on
how to cope with a rising energy bills
heading into the winter one restaurant
in Cheshire has taken matters into its
own hands in a protest at the impact of
spiraling costs the owners of The Next
Door restaurant are opening without the
use of electricity or gas
so here to tell us a little bit more is
the owner Vicky Nuttall a very good
morning to you Vicki natal thanks so
much for talking to us so tell us a
little bit about what you're calling a
Back to Basics event
uh yeah I'd love to thank you for having
me we um we're actually putting an event
together it's a uh a nine course tasting
event uh with the drinks pairing that
we're gonna deliver entirely without the
use of any power from from start to
finish so that's during all the prep and
then actually the delivery of it as well
it's um it's been a big challenge for us
to put together
so tell us a little bit about how you're
going to cook stuff how you're going to
keep food fresh I think even you're not
using Refrigeration are you
no no so we've um had an incredible
collection of like-minded businesses
come together to help us deliver this uh
this incredible kind of task
um so we've had a chuckle of an Company
Harrison that have agreed to lend us an
incredible Charcoal Oven for the evening
I will also be using some fire pits
grills
um our suppliers are on board they're
delivering Goods actually in the minute
that we need them even our vegetable
suppliers actually harvesting and
bringing the vegetables to us
um that's growing field we have got an
incredible Bakery on board the bear
Bakery have been developing a Sourdough
that they can make and prove without
using power or mixing and they'll be
baking it on the nights as well it's
just a huge Community effort to come
together and do this
so why are you doing this is this a
protest of of some kind or is this about
saving money and saving energy
so it's kind of both really
um I've just been listening to all of
your reporting there
um obviously politically and I I we are
normal people and I think a lot of
people feel like there are so many
decisions being made that are entirely
out of our control
that actually we sat down when the
energy crisis first started and thought
well what can we control what can we do
and
deciding to cut
the way we use energy was the only thing
that we had in our Arsenal so the it
spiraled from there and then when other
people started getting on board it
gained this amazing traction and and you
know some of these uh techniques we can
actually bring into our normal operation
um you know safely this has all been put
together with with us being able to
deliver it safely in a modern way
and lots of other restaurants lots of
companies up and down the country will
be feeling similar pressures I mean the
government would say it's brought in
help in the form of its business energy
support package how much difference is
that making to you
it makes a big difference I think it
makes a big difference to everyone we
were looking at at Power costs of a
monthly of around about 6 000 pounds and
now I think it'll be somewhere closer to
four
um but this is still that is
astronomically different to where we
were sitting this time you know even six
months ago and it's come out of the blue
and I don't think people are set up to
to change their Logistics to that level
required to actually bring our bills in
line it's it's it's still almost
unmanageable
um completely for so many people
well good luck with the event I hope it
goes well hope it it teaches you a few
tricks that you might be able to carry
on to the the normal day service but so
everything really interesting to hear
your plans thanks very much indeed thank
you thank you
now have you ever wondered what career
Prince William might have had if he
wasn't royalty well let's take a look at
this
maybe boxing the Prince of Wales have
put on his boxing gloves yesterday as he
celebrated the 10th anniversary
anniversary of the charity coach Corps
which was established by his Royal
Foundation he was also joined by the
Princess of Wales at the Copper box
arena in East London and uh I don't
think she boxed I haven't got any
pictures for her she did he praised the
power of sport and he congratulated the
organization which trains the next
generation of sports coaches
I'm not a boxer but look quite good to
me I don't know coming up for the next
hour here on Sky News breakfast we'll
have plenty more on those expectations
of another U-turn in the mini budget so
do stay with us
[Music]